Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow of death,
I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Good morning, church family.
My name is Brett McCoy and I am the student ministry director
here at Henderson Hills. And I've been here for a very long time. Yeah,
almost 10 months now. So, uh, if those of you,
if you are unfamiliar with who I am, uh, it's okay. I'll excuse it this time.
But, uh, we are coming up on my, uh, one year, um,
one year anniversary here. So I started on August 15th,
and it was just this past week where I had my, um,
very informal interview at Starbucks, um,
which is like Henderson Hills North. I don't know if you guys knew that or not,
but, uh, anyway, that was, uh, that was, that was like a year ago, uh,
this past week. So, um, it's been,
it's been kind of a fun week to look back and, uh, see where we've been. Um,
I do wanna say that, you know,
I dreamed of this moment of being here, sharing with you guys today.
Um, and I don't mean like it's a dream come true. I mean,
I had a weird dream about it a couple nights ago. Um,
TR Lewis was leading worship. Why? Why?
Someone had to come up in the middle of my sermon and get something from me.
And it was very, it was really weird. So I hope nothing like that happens, uh,
this morning. Uh, perhaps you're visiting here and you're wondering, Hey,
why,
why have there been so many different people preaching over the past few weeks?
Uh, and here's the deal. Our pastor, uh, John Wilmuth is on,
uh, sabbatical. And what that means is every five years, um,
our, our pastor lead teaching pastor gets a sabbatical several weeks off to just
relax, reflect, and get refocused.
So if you've been visiting for the past several weeks and you're like,
what's going on here? What's the deal? Um, don't worry,
pastor John will be back. Or maybe you're like my son Flynn,
when he announced that his sabbatical was beginning, um, and he said,
I think it was something to the effect of, I, I don't necessarily want to go,
but I know that this was a choice that I made.
Flynn looked over at me and he goes, what did he do? It's okay.
He will, he'll be back. Oh, man. Uh,
this morning we're gonna be in Psalm, uh, 58 and, uh,
it's, the title this morning is, uh, is Bad guys.
Good god. All right, bad guys. Good God. So if you're kind of wondering,
uh, where that's coming from,
we're gonna get into a little bit of background from the Old Testament book of
First Samuel Chapter 19. So, uh,
we'll be in a couple different places this morning. Uh, of course, Psalm 58,
but first Samuel, uh, 19,
I would like to give a little background on a scripture.
So especially in the Psalms, when you're reading those, those psalms, you can,
uh,
see and understand kind of where the person is coming from as they wrote
this psalm.
So first Samuel 19 verse 11 through 18.
That's where we're gonna start this morning.
One Samuel 19 verses 11 through 18.
Saul King Saul sent messengers to David's house to watch him
that he might kill him in the morning. But Michael, David's wife told him,
if you don't, if you do not escape with your life tonight, tomorrow,
you'll be killed. So Michael let David down through the window,
and he fled away and escaped.
Michael took an image and laid it on the bed and put a pillow of goat's
hair at its head and covered it with clothes. And when Saul,
when Saul sent messengers to take David, she said, he's sick.
Then Saul sent the messengers to see David saying,
bring him to me in the bed that I may kill him. And when the messengers came in,
behold the image was in bed with the pillow of goat's hair at its head.
Saul said to Michael,
why have you deceived me and thus let my enemy go so that he may escape?
And Michael answered Saul, he said to me, let me go. Why should I kill you? Now,
David fled and escaped, and he became,
he came to Samuel at Rama and told him all that Saul had done to him,
and he and Samuel went and lived at Naau.
This is one of the many times that King Saul attempted to kill
David, who was the future.
King David was a loyal subject to King Saul.
Many of the things that David had accomplished served to
benefit Saul in his kingship,
but Saul didn't see it that way. Saul instead saw it as a threat.
He was jealous of David and this story,
Saul sends these men to go and watch David sleep
so that they know exactly where he is gonna be,
and in the morning they're gonna kill him. So Michael,
who's Saul's daughter, by the way, David's wife helps him escape out the window.
Then she puts a statue in his bed,
covers it with goat's hair, puts clothes on it, and puts blankets on.
So when these guys come in, she's like, oh, he can't come out to play.
He's sick, right? And they're like, oh. And so then they go,
their job was to kill him, but then they just leave and they go, tell Saul, oh,
he was sick. He couldn't come out. Saul's like, b bring the whole bed.
And the guys are like, oh, okay. And then, uh,
David escapes out the window and goes to hang out
with Samuel. They go to live at Na off,
which is like a shepherd's camp. Such a relatable story.
We've all been there, right? We've all been there.
Our father-in-law, who's also our boss, hates us, right? Decides,
you know what done with that guy? Let's kill him. You know,
you've probably experienced that before. And then, you know,
our wife helps us escape out the window, right?
Just lowers us down and then puts a statue in our bed,
covers it with goat hair and clothes. And then the guys,
the murder squad who shows up to try to take us out, she's like, oh,
he can't come out. You guys understand, right? It's a, it's,
it's a relatable story. It's something we've all experienced. All right?
All right, well maybe that's not exactly true. Um,
but all of that, joking aside, David here,
he's in a pretty tough spot.
David's in a pretty tough spot and he's experiencing,
he's experiencing a very difficult situation.
And it is against that context that David has written.
Psalm 59.
So turn over few pages in your Bible to Psalm chapter
59.
Again,
that just provides a little context as to where we're gonna be this morning.
What we're gonna do is go ahead and read through the entire Psalm here,
and then we'll come back and, uh, break it down a little bit.
So join me there in Psalm 59, as we read in my Bible,
this is titled,
deliver Me From My Enemies to the Choir Master According
to Do Not Destroy, which just sounds like a metal song. All right?
A MTM of David when Saul sent men to watch his house in order to kill him.
And then we get into Psalm 59 verse one,
deliver me from my enemies. Oh my God,
protect me from those who rise up against me,
deliver me from those who work evil and save me from blood.
Thirsty men for behold, they lie in, wait for my life.
Fierce men stir up strife against me for no transgression
or sin of mine. Oh Lord, and no fault of mine, they run and make ready,
awake, come to meet me and see you Lord,
God of hosts are God of Israel,
rouse yourself and punish all the nations.
Spare none of those who treacherous plot evil
sayah.
Each evening they come back howling like dogs and prowling about the city.
There they are bellowing with their mouths,
with swords in their lips for who they think will hear us.
But you, oh Lord, laugh at them. You hold all the nations in derision.
Oh my strength, I will watch for you, for you, oh God, are my fortress.
My God in his steadfast love will meet me.
God will let me look in triumph on my enemies. Kill them,
not lest my people forget.
Make them tarter by your power and bring them down, oh Lord,
our shield for the sin of their mouths, the words of their lips.
Let them be trapped in their pride for the cursing and lies
that they utter consume them in wrath. Consume them till they are no more,
that they may know that the God,
that God rules over Jacob to the ends of the earth sayah
each evening they come back howling like dogs and prowling about the city.
They wander about for food and growled. If they do not get there, Phil,
but I will sing of your strength.
I will sing aloud of your steadfast love in the morning for you have been to me,
a fortress and a refuge in the day of my distress, oh my strength.
I will sing praises to you for you, oh God are my fortress,
the God who shows me steadfast love.
The first thing that I want us to see here is that God is
near the desperate.
God is near the desperate
in the first seven verses. David is showing us some things here.
First off, there is an acknowledgement that God can save him.
David has experienced this type of deliverance before.
If you remember,
David is the guy that fought in battles and faced hardened
warriors.
If you'll remember earlier in the story of David,
we hear of this song that the people sang. If you're unfamiliar with it,
it's a really uplifting song that says Saul has killed his
thousands, and David has killed his 10 thousands.
Who doesn't want a song like that written about him? Right?
Like the people would sing these songs about their kings.
But this was while Saul was still the king.
They would say Saul's killed thousands and David his 10 thousands,
probably the beginning of David's problems with Saul.
But David knew that God could deliver him because he had been
in battles before.
David's the same guy who fought the giant Goliath to the death
when no one in the world gave him a chance to win that battle.
David knew that God would deliver him.
And if you remember in that story, the people are like, dude,
what makes you think you can go fight this nine and a half foot tall giant?
And David's like, well, when I was watching my father's sheep,
I've killed lions and I've killed bears and I've killed tigers. Oh my,
all right, maybe not that last part. But he said, I've killed lions,
I've killed bears in any other type of animal that tries to come and take me or
take any of my sheep. I have been able to kill them.
God delivered me then and God is going to deliver me now.
And that is this anthem that is repeated throughout all of David's life.
He's been in dire situations before. He has been desperate before,
and he knows that God is near him.
Think about the situations of desperation in your own life,
those moments when you didn't feel like you had anywhere else where you could
go. Where did you go?
James four eight says that as we are submitting ourselves to God,
that if we draw near to God, he will draw near to us.
In Matthew seven, verses seven and eight, in the Sermon on the Mount,
Jesus says, ask and it will be given to you.
Seek and you will find knock and it will be open to you.
For everyone who asks, receives,
and to the one who seeks fines and to the one who knocks,
it will be open.
The idea here is that when we are desperate for God
and we are looking for God, we will find him.
God's not hiding. He's not hiding from any of us.
That's not what he's in the business of doing.
When you and I are desperate for him,
he is near to us.
All you have to do is look for him. He's not the one,
he's not the one that's hiding.
Maybe you're desperate right now.
Maybe it's a time when you are sick or a loved one is dealing with
some sort of illness or difficulty.
Maybe it's a difficult time at work and you're trying to figure out what's next.
Maybe you're not quite to the end of your rope yet, but you're getting close.
Get desperate. Look for God. Now,
while you are in the midst of this desperate time,
God is near the desperate.
So David spends the first seven verses talking about that idea of being
desperate. But then in verses eight through 11,
David reminds us that God is good at all times.
That's the second point to ponder this morning.
God is good at all times.
Look right there in verse eight. But you, oh, Lord,
laugh at them. You hold all the nations in derision.
He spent the first part of this psalm asking God to step in.
He describes the evil that he's facing. He says, the people are evil,
blood thirsty, fierce, treacherous, howling like dogs,
bellowing and sneaky.
And then David starts to describe God.
He says God is so big that he holds entire nations in derision.
The word derision means contemptuous, ridicule or mockery.
It's like looking at someone's plans and laughing.
Several years ago,
there was a guy in the N B A named Debe Mtumbo.
Anybody here know who Mtumbo is? Some of you guys are like, what? De Kimbe.
Mtumbo was like a seven foot two basketball player in the N nba.
He played during the, the time when Michael Jordan played.
And a little bit later than that, uh,
Mtumbo is I think second on the all time
leaders of blocking shots.
So people did not get too many shots up over Debe. Mtumbo,
some of you guys are gonna go home and YouTube mtumbo. All right? Um,
you should. All right. It's a thing of beauty. But whenever,
whenever someone would shoot a shot and he would reach up and block their shot,
boom, sometimes knock it outta bounds,
sometimes he would swat it all the way to the other end of the basketball court.
He would do this thing where he would wag his finger.
Some of you guys are like, oh, now, okay, now I got it.
He would wag his finger and he would smile and the guy's
smile was huge. And he would have this huge smile on his face,
and he would laugh. He would be like, ha ha ha. No, no.
And he did that to people all the time. And as I read through this passage,
I was reminded of Dec dec, Kimbe, Mtumbo.
I know my brain's kind of in a weird place right now,
but I think in my mind,
that's kind of how it is with God.
When nations are planning things that are going against his will,
only thing is you might get lucky and dunk on Mato
Mambo. You're not dunking on God. All right? It's not happening.
But God would look at our plans or the plans of the nations or any plans that
goes against his will, and he would just laugh like,
okay, good luck with that. Are you sure? You sure about that?
That's what God's saying you. Is this really what you're gonna try? Okay,
go ahead. But that's what David's talking about.
He's saying God will laugh
At the things that people try. In Psalm 1 26,
and in Psalm 37 13, God says this,
I will laugh at your calamity and mock you. When terror strikes,
he laughs at the wicked because he sees their day approaching.
So God is good at all times,
even when the nation stands in opposition to his will.
Sometimes I feel like we can relate to that.
God is our fortress and his steadfast love will meet us where we
are.
David also says here that God will let him look in triumph over his
enemies. We know that God did that for David,
and I don't know what that looks like for us, but as followers of Jesus,
just think about for a moment what you have already overcome in your life.
What enemies were working against you,
what enemies were standing in the way of God's will for your life.
Sickness, despair, addiction,
family problems, financial issues.
Nothing is too great for God to overcome.
We believe that today God is good at all times.
Remember David is saying all this stuff about God when he is in a dark place
and people are after him.
And it might even seem like the bad guys are gonna win,
But David knows better. David knows better.
The third point to ponder this morning is this God is just
to the wicked. God is just to the wicked.
There's another section of verses here, uh, 12 through 15.
He's not only near the desperate, he's not only good at all times,
but he is just to the wicked.
It means that those who stand in opposition to him will be
defeated and will get what's coming to them.
No one is going to get away with what they're doing. You and I,
with the benefit of looking back into history are able to see that yes, in fact,
Saul and his army and his followers did perish.
And in some cases, Saul took other people down with him.
David had faith that God was going to deliver him, but also punish the wicked.
It's easy to say that, but sometimes it's harder to come up with those actions.
Sometimes it's harder to come up with those actions. But David lived that out.
David demonstrated this, this faith in God,
and he never took matters into his own hands. Like in first Samuel 24,
which is an event that took place after this story,
David and Saul were fighting once again with Saul's guys chasing
David and his men. And then all of a sudden, mid battle,
Saul has to make a pit stop. King Saul's gotta go to the bathroom
again, middle of the battle, not the ideal time, but whatever. All right,
so Saul goes into a cave and goes in and starts using the restroom.
That's the cave where David is. Some of you guys remember that story.
And as as Saul is using the bathroom, David's men are like,
oh, bro, this is your chance. Go take him out. Like,
now, could you think of a better time? And David's like,
I, I, nope. Not gonna do it.
And so what David does is he cuts off a piece of Saul's robe while he's going to
the bathroom. Ick. All right? And he picks up that piece of his robe.
And after Saul finishes, he goes outside and he's hanging out with his army.
And David walks out and he is like, Hey Saul,
check this out. That's a piece of your robe, bro.
He's like, I could have ended you right there. And I didn't do it
because David had the faith that God was gonna handle it.
God was gonna handle it. Now,
the application of this one is a little difficult for some of us to live with.
I may say that I believe that God is going to be the one who delivers judgment,
but I might have a hard time showing that I believe it when I've been
wronged. What do I wanna do?
Start flapping my gums about it. Start talking about it. Oh,
you're not gonna believe this.
Tell whoever will listen to how I've been treated unfairly.
This is not a demonstration that I believe that God is going to deal with it.
It's like I want to take those matters into my own hands.
If we really believe it,
it means that we realize that God is going to judge the ungodly in the book of
Romans chapter 12, verse 19, when talking about the marks of a true Christian,
a true follower of Jesus. Paul says this, never avenge yourselves,
but leave it to the wrath of God. For it is written, vengeance is mine,
I will repay, says the Lord.
So David was actually confessing a behavior that is attributed to a
Christ follower.
So live in such a way that you believe that God will be
just to the wicked. It is not our job.
Woo.
That's a tough one.
And then the fourth and final point to ponder this morning is that
God is a refuge for his people.
The last two verses in Psalm 59,
verses 16 and 17, those verses say this one more time.
I will sing of your strength.
I will sing aloud of your steadfast love in the morning.
For you have been to me,
a fortress and a refuge in the day of my distress, oh my strength.
I will sing praises to you for you, oh God are my fortress,
the God who shows me steadfast love.
David once again brings it back to a focus on God's
character. You can't go wrong when you're focusing on who God is.
David describes God as a refuge for his people. He talks about God's strength,
his steadfast love, his availability as a fortress,
a refuge strength, and so on.
This is interesting because in verse 16,
David refers to this in the past tense,
did you see that
you have been to me a fortress?
He's counting on a God that has already been there for him,
God who has been there in the past.
And then,
and then he's telling us at the end that he has faith
because God will be there again in the morning emphasizing that God
will see him through the dark night because of who God has been.
David has hope for the present and the future.
He's going to tell people about it.
He's going to sing about the goodness of God. In this demonstration,
David is telling us that he has a reason to sing and
will continue.
Not only is that who God was to David,
but that continues to be who He is to us.
God is the place where we can run to for protection.
God is the one who will deliver us.
God is the one who has been there in the past,
and he is the one who will continue to be there in the future.
He does not abandon His people.
No matter what you have felt, no matter what you've been dealt,
God has not and will not abandon you.
And I,
I want you guys to grasp that today because there may be some people here who
really need to hear this.
You're here for a purpose today.
God loves you and he wants you to be part of his family.
And today he might be calling you to salvation.
Maybe you don't know Jesus.
Maybe you are not a part of his family.
God is calling you to that today.
Maybe he's reminding you of that today.
Maybe you are a follower of Jesus,
but you feel like you are far from him.
Perhaps because of a situation like this in David's life
that is no fault of his own. Maybe that's where you are,
through no fault of your own.
Are you where you are perhaps and you feel like,
I don't know why this is happening.
Maybe part of it is to help get you to that desperate place where you will
seek God and draw near to him.
God wants to be your refuge. Let him be that today.
Whatever it is, just know that you are loved
and just a moment we're going to pray and we are going to sing.
And as we wrap up our service today, we're gonna sing.
We're gonna sing some songs, we're gonna have a time of giving.
But when we wrap up this service,
we are going to have people around the outside here who want to pray for you.
They're gonna have lanyards on
and they are going to offer up an opportunity for you to go to them and say,
Hey, would you just pray for me? Like I need to be reminded of, of who God is.
I need to be reminded of this refuge. I'm dealing with some stuff right now.
And if you will go and you will do that,
they will pray and they will lift you up to the Lord.
You can pray with them or you can just let them pray for you.
That's what's gonna be happening here at the end of our service,
after we take an opportunity to worship together today.
If you're sick and you need healing,
let us pray for you physically, spiritually,
mentally,
Just like the scriptures talk about in James,
draw near to God and he will draw near to you.